[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
May 12th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
younger workers say achieving work-life
balance is important yet many feel their
job helps Define them and they can't
shake the needs of their job outside of
work hours wsj on the clock columnist
Callum borschers looked into how
Millennials and gen Z workers are
dealing with this struggle and he's here
now so Callum younger workers like a lot
of age groups in the workplace have
placed extra emphasis on work-life
balance in recent years how are younger
workers handling that when they're
actually dealing with deadlines and
co-workers and bosses making demands I'd
say they're dealing with it in a very
disjointed way Jr I mean when Deloitte
did its annual survey of these young
professionals and asked them what
qualities do you most admire in a peer
unsurprisingly somebody who is able to
maintain work-life balance or live life
on their own terms ranked very highly
that was more impressive to Young
workers than somebody's salary or their
job title or the house or card that they
drove and yet if you ask those same
young professionals well what's really
important to your own sense of identity
their job was much more highly rated
than things like Hobbies or exercise or
fashion or listening to music so there's
this disconnect between what we admire
and others and what we actually practice
for ourselves Hmm this sounds like a
tricky balance is this an easier said
than done type of scenario it is it's
much easier to say that you're going to
have work-life balance than to actually
do it the poster person for this who I
spoke with in the course of my reporting
was a woman named Catherine Smith lakari
who literally carries around a card with
the words work life balance in her
wallet because she says it's one of her
core values and yet she's working around
the clock she tells me now she's an
entrepreneur she has a consultancy for
small businesses and she feels like she
owes it to her clients and to her small
team to really be on call at all times
so for her actually work-life balance is
really more something she tries to
protect for her team she wants to be
respectful of their time but for herself
it's almost non-existent and a lot of
the conversation about work-life balance
especially among younger workers is
playing out on social media hashtag
quiet quitting and so on how is that
shaping the way that younger people are
approaching this yeah they're doing it
for the gram so to speak J.R right like
they're posting these heavily curated
images that show robust personal lives
and then they're going right back to the
grind in some cases so it can appear as
though they have tremendous work-life
balance and it's not the reality I'm
thinking of a conversation I had with a
young man named Daniel zoderer who is
the executive director of a non-profit
that addresses food insecurity and he
says he works basically the equivalent
of two full-time jobs every weekend lots
of nights finally took a few days off to
go hiking in the Catskills recently and
he told me he was thinking mid hike
about the LinkedIn post he was going to
write with a picture of himself hiking
about the importance of taking breaks so
it really sort of permeates a lot of
people's thinking so who are younger
workers role models in the workplace as
they struggle with this I'd say the role
models fall into a couple of buckets Jr
I mean there's one bucket of the type of
person who seems to totally break free
of societal expectations so like I spoke
with a young woman named deshani casual
she's in her mid-20s and she says she's
got like a friend who's living the
hashtag van life right like get out of
the office go kind of cruise around the
country work when you need to but like
seems totally detached and I think
that's sort of a fantasy for a lot of
young professionals and then there's
another type of person who's a role
model who is a little bit more senior
maybe it's somebody's boss and the young
professionals looking at that person and
saying wow he or she seems to just have
it all they got a great job they got a
great family they make a lot of money
how do they manage to do all those
things at the same time so I'd say those
are the two types of role models that
came up over and over in my
conversations Callum earlier in the week
on the show we discussed how younger
people can set the stage for a
successful long-term career if they can
land a good job by age 30. now wouldn't
that mean in their 20s they might have
to join what we often hear of as the
hustle culture to stand out and get
ahead it could very well mean that and I
think that's the pressure that a lot of
these young professionals say keeps them
from maintaining the kind of work-life
balance that they admire in theory right
because for a lot of these folks some of
them started their careers in the
recession of the Arts and of course
we've all gone through the pandemic in
more recent years so if you're 10 or 15
years into your working life let's say
you've had a pretty disruptive time and
I heard from some of these workers that
has contributed to a sense that if you
don't sort of hustle now or score some
of those professional wins while you can
it's really going to hurt you in the
long run Callum you wrote a comment them
last month about managers wanting hard
workers and they're hiring older workers
to fill that need now for younger people
maintaining free time is one thing but
could it cost them down the line it
could and I think that one of the things
that we still haven't sorted out is how
much of the cultural changes around work
that we've seen in the last few years
are going to be sustainable and how many
of them were actually sort of a
temporary function of a really tight
labor market and or the pandemic I think
employers were very understanding about
people wanting to work from home let's
say they've also been pretty
understanding about respecting people's
boundaries and saying oh you know sure I
won't email you after hours or I'll try
to use the schedule send feature on my
email account right so that that hits
your inbox on Monday morning instead of
over the weekend I do wonder whether
that will continue if employers are in a
more powerful position whether they will
return to the pre-pandemic expectation
that you're sort of on call for me all
the time and eventually gen Z and
Millennials are going to be the lion
chair of the workforce and so it seems
that there might not be another group to
sort of compare them to to find harder
workers yes and that
and that biggest case for the changes
we've seen of the last few years lasting
longer right I mean so if more
Millennials and gen's ears end up in
management they can kind of set the tone
right so if they really do want to
prioritize work-life balance if they're
the boss they can set the corporate
culture in that fashion but you got to
get there first right so the question is
can you rise enough doing things the way
you want to now as a young worker to
eventually have enough power to change
the corporate culture when you get there
that was Wall Street Journal on the
clock columnist Callum borschers and
that's it for your money briefing our
producer is mohsin Ali our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris zinsley I'm
your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
thank you